des fois je vois même des chiffres sur
mes lives je suis pas en train de jappo
timone qu'ils sont 7000 je ne comprends
pas c'est en train de tourner avec mon
vélo pour faire éclore des oeufs
des fois je ne comprends pas pourquoi il
ya autant de gens qui me regardent
clairement
[Musique]
oh
fur et à mesure va forcément je passais
de plus en plus de temps sur la console
et mes notes commencé à un minimum
descendront jeu restait quand même un
bon élève mais j'étais pas en le premier
de la classe tout ça est forcément mes
parents ont commencé à se poser des
questions et en même temps il voyait un
enfant qui bat qu'ils étaient heureux de
ce qu'il est c'est-à-dire qu'ils passent
à côté de ma chambre il voyait que
faisait cueillir et du coup ils ont
compris au fur et à mesure que c'est ma
passion
donc forcément ça reste des parents ils
m'ont poussé pour les études pour
l'école et au fur à mesure bas ils ont
vu que c'était vraiment la console qui
faisait de moi ce que j'étais et
ils m'ont ils m'ont aidé et m'ont
soutenu et j'ai eu la chance d'avoir des
parents comme ça clairement
[Musique]
on a été dans les journaux locaux
et voilà donc on était un peu la fierté
d'être en bio c'était cool mais
l'organisateur de lalanne s'est barré je
crois avec le cashprize avec les tickets
d'entrée
donc première déception dans le gaming
mais mais voilà c'est là que tu te tu te
rends force entre guillemets que tu te
dis que c'est un monde de requins faut
faire attention et on a continué on a
persévéré
maintenant aujourd'hui je m'en suis sait
plus trop
[Musique]
poupet le samedi matin le vendredi lundi
donc forcément quand tu es en terminale
s tu peux plus vivre sur ses acquis si
tu commences à louper des programmes de
mode etc
tu t'en sors plus au fur et à mesure
j'ai été vraiment en train en train de
noyer dans les cours j'étais vraiment
moyen dans les deux domaines ça soit le
gaming et justement les cours et du coup
ben moi j'ai fait un choix j'ai je
partis en mode tête baissée dans le
gaming
je me suis dit je reprendrai études plus
tard et au final pas je regrette pas du
tout aujourd'hui c'est une vie
d'entrepreneur ça s'est super bien passé
pour moi et je regrette aucunement
[Musique]
au début quand j'ai joué des gens il
m'insultait pas mais me disais pourquoi
tu vois ce jeu c'est un jeu il n'est pas
très beau il est pas machin etc
voici juste les gars je kiffe en fait je
kiffe y jouer donc voilà et quelques
semaines quelques mois plus tard le jeu
explose donc bah moi j'étais déjà bien
placé dessus et c'est forcément on va
jouer alors que ça marchait pas c'est
incroyable de voir même tu vois des
griezmann ne tape et des danses c'est
n'importe quoi et fo réclament à m'a
énormément apporté donc j'étais entre
guillemets déjà quelqu'un avant mais son
méfait en ait marre ouvert une porte que
je nai jamais j'aurais pu ouvrir je
pense avec avec n'importe quel jeu donc
j'en serai éternellement reconnaissant
ça c'est sûr
dacca
[Musique]
non
ce côté caritatif je pense que c'est un
peu nos parents et surtout ma mère qui
nous a inculqué ça donc là mais la une
alala le truc ou 2 to share justement
qui qui aide un peu les enfants
hospitalisés et nous quand on était
jeunes on avait pas mal de problèmes
suite à notre âge on est et on est tous
asthmatiques à 100% dans les enfants nés
cinq enfants
enfin tous pratiquement tous et du coup
on a en a souvent fait des cessions à
l'hôpital qui durerait quelques temps et
je pense que du coup ça restait un peu
dans dans les moeurs si je puis dire
[Musique]